aujourd'hui de 9h à 12h
jours où nous avons visité un total de
seize personnes dont deux
code uper fourni et bien sûr
chambre max coexisté 12 personnes
servi dans la véranda et et deux
une personne a refusé de visiter du tout
Nom
la vérité réagit différemment tout le monde appelle
invités aujourd'hui pouvons-nous vous joindre
nous disons disons oui bien sûr seulement
1 bâtiment 1
aussi longtemps que possible et tout pour l'instant sauf
donc alors que les visiteurs ne sont pas particulièrement nombreux
mais généralement à ce moment bien sûr nous avons déjà
c'est-à-dire qu'une personne 20 30 points passe
Aujourd'hui, il n'y en avait plus que deux.